hi i'd like to talk about
the mind's
mind i've not
read anything or done anything i'll
research this this
is just my take on it
i hope you find it enjoyable and
the main thing is it's to challenge your
mind
i've been posting on youtube
aikido many aikido talking
films and i want to expand into
talking about the other things that i do
and i've started a patreon
site where people contribute
and i go into depth and hopefully
the program will
make it enjoyable for those taking part
but this one i'd like to talk
about general people anybody can
listen to this and it may help you you
don't have to be a martial artist
it can be just for the general human
being
i'm going to call it the four minds
and how do i see the four minds in no
particular order
we can have the adult mind
the child's mind the ego
mind the subconscious mind
the subconscious mind may get a little
complicated for those
once i get there but the moment
i'd like to talk about the adult mind
we may wake up in the morning and
if it's not a work day
i think i'll go for a ride on my bike
i think uh today i'll read that book
that i've got
i'll go for a run
i'm gonna tie the house
i should do some sewing knitting
i'm going to go out and do photography
this is
to me the adult mind we decide
what we're going to do that day
and we try and accomplish it sometimes
things get in the way and we don't quite
achieve what we want but that's to me
the
normal straightforward adult mind that
we all have
and um should be able to relate to
easily
the child's mind may be forgotten about
now by the adult
doesn't matter whether you're male
female
you know we we forget what it was like
to be a child
and that the child says many things that
uh
an adult would feel embarrassed to say
but really those childhood
thoughts or insecurities
may have bled into the adults
for argument say
if you were to go and sit on
a park bench cross your legs sit
sitting there on the park bench closing
your eyes pretending
i think i'll just meditate
i say pretend because
you know you're going to get disturbed
you'll feel people will walk by and
think
how odd you are
that possibly will disturb beyond you
that would be perhaps coming from the
child's mind
but what about the honesty the child
says something
doesn't realize that what they've said
would never be said by an adult they ask
questions
don't they why'd you do that what does
that mean
and i don't say oh they're they're
learning
they're they're gaining knowledge
if we could keep that child mind into
adulthood
and not be so frightened of speaking out
when we
think that we should speak out or
perhaps doing silly things that an adult
may not do i'm not going to say any
particular
thing because it's up to you to decide
what you
consider maybe rebellious
or silly that an
adult would do but may seem childish to
others
then we've got the ego mind
i remember when i used to smoke and
drink
after a few drinks even though trying to
give up
smoking the ego mine would say
why shouldn't you have a cigarette if
you want one
you can have one you know you work
hard you don't have to be governed by
walls
have a cigarette okay i will have one
have another drink if you want one
or if somebody tells you some
what to do you might say it's
stubbornness
it might just be the ego mind saying i'm
not being told what to do
by them
where's the compassionate mind
we don't seem to have that but perhaps
that's the subconscious mind
how many times have you said
yes i i knew that was wrong to do that
but
i'd done it anyhow
something was telling me that
not to go out today but i did
i had a feeling i should go another way
today
i don't know what it is about that but
there's something telling me
you know take a different route
or today i've got a feeling i should be
aware
i don't know why but i feel that i might
be a little bit
vulnerable today
it's something telling me to take care
the subconscious mind is very clever
very knowledgeable but we don't listen
to it much
we don't listen to the child mind do we
but we
we had all that all those years ago in
my case
well if they're all within us
why not bounce from one to the other
why didn't you choose perhaps today
ask the subconscious
should i read a book and all of a sudden
if you get a guilt feeling
perhaps you should learn to meditate
what is that guilt feeling for
has it been inbred over the years
perhaps it has a lot of people don't do
things because
they feel guilty
those that don't feel guilty is it
because
they deserve to have a day off
is it the ego mind saying you deserve a
day off do what you like
is that being stubborn um
the compassionate internal mind of the
subconscious
will only be kind to you it will only
advise you
on what perhaps you wish to consider
for your own good for your own best
interest
so to me we have four minds
and then as i say no particular order
the ego mind the child mind
the adult mind
the subconscious mind
if if you were religious it may be
called
your soul in
and it knows everything about you
it knows your weaknesses
it knows your strengths even though you
may not think you have strengths
or perhaps your ego mind tells you you
have a lot of strengths
i hope this will help you to just
consider those
minds that i've talked about
and if you wish to know more and go
deeper
perhaps you'd like to join me on my
patreon site
the details are below thank you for your
time